salut à tous alors aujourd'hui je suis
avec alex sa famille et des nouveaux
abonnés qu'on initie à la pêche éléments
il ya également le petit rasta
alors on attaque tout de suite belle
soeur de mme diallo
du coup je vais me sortir un beau palais
thun est destiné à les jours sa pote
choc
qu'est-ce que j'ai encore assez comme
toi non ouais ouais ouais si c'était si
tu rejoins les filtres à temps c'est pas
le même droit à pêcher deux fois le même
ah c'est quoi c'est une genre de morceau
de voitures télécommandées donc la
titraille incommodante d'essuie glace
vin très anciens spla ouais c'est ça
owen tubes dont kenneth aucun nom à voir
ouais kokor coco oui j'ai quelque chose
qu associer ces trucs parce que c'est
ce qui est bien c'est que tu sais jamais
ce qu'ils font tomber des péniches quand
même des fois il suffit d'un coup de
chance
lvl a fait tomber son porte-monnaie ou
quoi bah ouais on s'affronte à les
fourchettes d'elle [ __ ] d'amarrage fait
par notre ami alex et et ça c'est ouais
non j'ai pas cillé du doré bon pour moi
je pense que ma propre rôle avait buggé
mais on a sorti un beau cadeau halkin
s'accroche là ouais c est peut-être le
reste de la moto des fois ça pour moi
c'est une mob
non c'est pas un vélo pour marquer ouais
c'est trop grosse et trop gros sel et
les modes de de l'époque la cuillère en
voiture on a tiré dix fois au même
endroit c'est encore un os oui enfin
avait quand même quand même en battant
vaduz qui optent la ramasse et et salons
officiels le manche en plastique là
c'est nickel
[Musique]
il ya moins de base si je la bats a
c'est qu'on sent on dit qu lunettes ou
je crois qu'elles sont dans 3 4 sont
dedans n'est simple aurel attend
franchement c'est lourd put tu vois il
suffit d'un coup de chance le mec il a
fait tomber ses lunettes de marque et
voilà elle est devenue un vrai par
contre non c'est pourrissement et big le
total on voit absolument rien en fait sa
foulée ouais ouais c'est vrai que c'est
flou et hommes ça fout les boules que
sur des lunettes de vue
oui oui oui dont il brigue le 01/12 bon
ça reste sympa et du mal à alimenter la
boîte quoi s'alimenter la beauté alors
pensé fera encore des trucs que tu vois
c'est remplir ce serait mon chien
repoussée je vais te baigner voile et la
toiture touche quoi
alors d'où votre truc trois ici à huy
soin de lui au [ __ ] c'est quoi ça ce
matin
ouais mais comparez pas à les montrer
nous ouais ça n'a pas l'air scooter je
pense que c'est quoi franchement là
c'est dur à dire
un coffre on te regarde ça pollue ça ah
ouais c'est qu'à droite il est pas là
là j'ai un truc pas mal pas mal
il enroule un rapport il est vraiment
lourd
donc là on a sécurisé la poubelle
et on innove et tire à 2 d'accord des
mois sur lui non oui allait exploser la
main bien joué les gars ont rappelé aux
rapaces cas là on met notre voiture un
vol de tableau
voilà c'est la fin de la vidéo avec tous
les abonnés mon ami alex est tout bon
conte en remontée du lourd comme
d'habitude avec surtout cette paire de
lunettes
donc voilà le résultat pour les lignes
et ralph lauren elle semble en bon état
mais comme vous pouvez voir il ya des
reflets bizarre à l'envoi ça fait un peu
rose comme ça et d'être est donc à mon
avis ils ont pris cher dans l'eau donc
je ne sais pas si je peux encore les
donner à une association ou quoi donc je
vais avoir dit le moins commentaires ce
que vous en pensez
en tout cas super travail et à bientôt
pour une prochaine vidéo
[Musique]